[Applaudissements]
par les manucures c'est fou il rentrait
un trait montluc
on parlait manucurist savent avant jeudi
reconnaît oui je dis tu as parlé dans la
sphère que sada et ouais il s'installe
et puis il disparaît il parle
donc ça c'est pas prise il est considéré
comme un fugitif et oui il est en cavale
il a disparu corps et biens
à la manière de xavier dupont de
ligonnès n'ont pas pour les méfaits
commis mais pour le la cavale la
disparition il s'est volatilisé alors
moi j'ai un scoop les chroniqueurs
figurez-vous qu'en 3e au collège louis
lumière à marly le roi j'avais une prof
d'espagnol qui s'appelait madame
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire sur
cette affaire là tout de suite on la
touche unis a ralenti à chaque fois
qu'on n'a pas de nouvelles d'un mec vous
faites un débat pour savoir s'ils en
cavale
beaucoup de débats jeudi à lui par
exemple non la une et vous faites c'est
notre pote tout va bien il est chez lui
n'est pas en cavale lui par exemple bas
aussi on n'a pas disparu il doit être
quelque part en train de faire bîmes eu
contre le mcs à côté c'est benjamin
castaldi et tous les soirs il est là sur
le plateau jeudi il y à un drame sur le
plateau gilles verdez a encore craqué on
a fait une rechute il a vu durera six
devraient volonté de discrimination et
on y reviendra au moment du choix de la
chanson peut-être mais il ya eu une
organisation fait pour vous éliminer et
elle n'est pas à mon avis étrangères à
votre couleur de peau alors gilles qui
serait plus simple mon chat c'est que tu
lance directement une application vous
en avez marre du racisme mais vous ne
savez pas comment le détecter
alors télécharger la nouvelle
application de gilles verdez le facho
scan grâce à l'application fachos scan
détecter si il y à du racisme
dans votre vie de tous les jours c'est
de l'islamophobie commercial vraie
volonté de discrimination
c'est de l'islamophobie commercial
attention le facho scan ne garantit pas
un résultat crédible à 100%
francis d'inadmissible pour finir ces
villes qui est pas mal proche où la
demande est aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de
savoir comment on parle de notre
émission sur les autres chaînes wii
vous connaissez les missions thema sur
arte et puis oui oui bien sûr voici le
thema spécial tpm pictures sens qu'on va
adorer merci
tip is french news boni tous aux
antennes en france 4 france cathy the
french and lease back nocentini en jaune
delphine ernotte style but the show is
used by cyril hanouna sur l'analyse afin
de vérifier mais quand je dis mon corps
forcément c'est tout mon corps laflaque
bassiste intéressante à mites cyril east
and fund and high tech par al ce dark à
dark à heidenheim deutsch woerth a beau
nicht à cet en-cas et m
ce concept of life et cela que j'aurais
very big jo n 6 la nonna excuses joy
with his life and a very particulier
l'alcool encore le dit
il est ici on dise ou graphiques when
the dark heart goes down is because aura
soit 1,03 et notre groupe fort de
hudgens the people
je reçois was discovered by the
professeur mohamed salim khimoun just
mixte 12 faculty of hammamet d'asra sera
i stein get fooled r angst odeurs
panique al imamayn grosse tarte
what is in this thing about ipm pie x
2,50 compagnie air france
after moulinex because they give the
opportunity to c 28 ans jeune
chroniqueur to work in tennis et sa
maison dit chroniqueur gilbert deux
odeurs ans michal maya audace typhi
poulet réseau gilles verdez the white
muslim guillaume johnson the king of the
night
isabelle morini-bosc comme highlander
awadi chic et dorment au look est un
oiseau léon zitrone un look à 10 go 10,6
bernard montiel the sound of the sun le
cari scolaire et la grippe n'a qu'un bon
petit noa nos jobs
oui oui dormant
das latvala bergesen barnhart estime tv
show vidéo gag un mythe menschen fallen
alnaha bint al bara et fut à ce qu'il
met hefti pmp et seconde continue the
answer les yes men the lights the big
professeur cyndi lauper french just want
to have fun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m